et notre invité politique ce matin s'est
Alexis Corbière bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ça va vous même député
la France insoumise de la
Seine-Saint-Denis on va parler ce qui
s'est passé hier à l'Assemblée nationale
évidemment mais d'abord l'actualité
marquée par ce drame à Nancy et cette
attaque au couteau hier qui a touché de
très jeunes enfants au-delà de les mois
de l'émotion évidemment il y a des
questions qui se posent et qui ont été
posées très vite hier par une partie de
la classe politique notamment sur la
politique migratoire est-ce que cet acte
pose des questions sur les règles
européennes en matière d'immigration
pour vous
je sais pas si à ce stade on peut dire
ça mais je ne crois pas
il faut avoir un peu de dignité on a vu
hier c'est assez éloquent comment
certains très chaud ce sont refroidis
quand on a su un peu plus de choses sur
cet homme et je mets encore beaucoup de
points d'interrogation parce que la
police enquête qu'est-ce qui se passe
etc mais
d'abord l'émotion
moi j'ai trouvé ça bien qui au moment de
recueillement à l'Assemblée nationale je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé au Sénat
peut-être la même chose sans doute
c'est-à-dire qu'on touche quelque chose
que nous sommes une nation il y a des
choses qui sont symboliquement
puissantes d'ailleurs qui touche même
au-delà de nos principes républicains
des enfants en bas âge c'est du jamais
vu l'horreur atteint niveau et tout le
monde c'est un peu arrêté un instant ça
ne veut pas dire que le débat politique
continue pas donc il faut surtout quand
on a peu d'informations garder cette
décence et pas faire feu de tout bois et
certains n'ont pas gardé j'ai eu
l'impression premièrement à l'Assemblée
nationale on a eu mais je veux pas non
plus moi alimenter ce que je suis en
train de dénoncer mais la présidente du
groupe
en marche immédiatement on a profité
pour essayer de flétrir ceux qui nous
faisait perdre du temps pour dénoncer le
coup de force qui était fait contre la
représentation nationale bon elle se
reconnaîtra je pense que elle-même elle
se dégrade en faisant ça elle voit elle
vaut mieux que ça elle vaut mieux que ça
même si c'est une opposante je pense
qu'elle vaut mieux que c'est sorti très
agressive très politicienne franchement
quand des enfants viennent d'être
poignardés on peut avoir des mots en
direction des familles des enfants et
pas jouer avec ça et puis on a vu
en quittant l'hémicycle de dédicatesse
et de vouloir immédiatement profiter
pour essayer d'éteindre la protestation
que nous faisons en temps bon et après
il y a ceux qui immédiatement
politique c'est une utilisation une
instrumentalisation politicienne alors
que nous étions tous recueillis mais que
ce qui se passait à l'Assemblée devait
avoir lieu et vouloir en quelque sorte
chlore la discussion et dire tout ça
quelle perte de temps alors que il se
passe des choses c'est bon enfin je veux
dire on a on a vu et c'est un peu c'est
grossier et je répète tout drame nous
percute mais quand il s'agit d'enfants
de 22 mois 300 en fait je veux dire des
choses qui nous sidère bon et qu'il y a
une part de mystère ou du moins on
espère que la justice la police nous
permettra d'y voir un peu plus clair ça
c'est une chose et puis après il y a
immédiatement le débat sur certains déjà
le traité d'islamiste manifestement
manifestement moi je suis très très
prudent il ne l'est pas et puis c'est un
homme qui
nos nationalité syrienne mais qui a
évacu en Suède qui avait un enfant avec
une femme suédoise qui était-il que
veut-il je ne sais pas moi là encore
parmi toutes les questions qu'il faut
poser mais il va de soi vraiment je suis
prudent il y a aussi quel est l'étape
psychiatrique de cet homme on verra
manifestant pas dans tes dents enfin on
peut s'attendre tout de même à la fois
au vu de ce qu'il a fait et puis de ce
que nous raconte la presse les
hurlements qui ne semblent pousser lors
des interrogatoires etc
il y a un sujet
qu'on me comprenne bien qui qui
peut-être que je le raccroche un peu de
manière imprudente à ça qui est celui de
la dégradation des politiques publiques
en termes de soins apportés aux gens qui
sont frappés de troubles psychiatriques
toujours du 30% des postes de médecins
sont non pourvu on a fermé des hôpitaux
et nous avons des gens extrêmement
perturbés qui sont pas pris en charge
quel que soit leur nationalité alors là
encore je parlais encore hier soir avec
un spécialiste la grande majorité des
gens perturbés ne sont pas des gens
dangereux mais perdons pas de vue encore
le l'assassin de l'infirmière l'autre
jour dans l'hôpital de
est autonome extrêmement perturbé bon
donc ça aussi il s'agit pas seulement
d'être ému mais de dire quelle politique
on fait quel prise en charge on a
comment les médecins qui s'occupent
infirmiers ont des moyens de lit de
soins parce que c'est aussi un problème
de santé publique il y a une autre
interrogation c'est le fait que cet
homme a obtenu le statut de réfugiés en
Suède pardon qu'il était donc entré de
manière régulière sur le territoire
français est-ce que pour vous il faut
poser la question des règles européennes
en matière d'immigration mais pas à pas
ce sujet je veux dire si cet homme avait
poignardé des enfants suédois vous et
moi on serait ému de la même façon donc
quel est le débat ne faisons pas croire
que ça qui augmente le crime faisant pas
croire qu'en raison de Schengen les
assassins viennent en France pour faire
leur larsent donc c'est un faux débat de
poser le débat sur la liberté de
circulation au sein de l'outils
observons après on peut avoir des
discussions de comment les gens là aussi
sont pris en charge comment leur dossier
sont étudiés quelle politique au niveau
européen en matière de de d'immigration
et pas avoir lieu et essayons d'avoir
une discussion grand angle politique dit
qu'il faut donner le statut de réfugiés
en dehors des pays de l'Union européenne
et de le pas les laisser
tranquillement en soit à tel point qu'il
avait épousé une Suédoise il fait un
enfant qui sans doute à la nationalité
avouer que c'est un profil quand même
qui dément ce côté immédiatement
menaçant de quelqu'un qui vient pour
profiter de nos allocations et faire le
crime en Europe les parcours humains
sont plus compliqués que ça et de toute
manière le sujet que nous avons quand on
parle de tout ça c'est celui que ce que
nous avons devant nous en raison des
grands dérèglements climatiques en
raison parfois des grands accords de
libre-échange qui ont perturbé des
économies raison des guerres il y a un
sujet que de toute manière certains pays
sont aujourd'hui dans un état de délabre
Montel que des milliers de gens vont
sont sur les routes c'est d'ailleurs
souvent pas vers l'Europe qui se dirige
initialement et qu'on peut monter des
barbelés solliciter toutes les armées
européennes on ne réglera pas le
problème si ce n'est déjà en essayant de
régler le problème tout de même on parle
de de la Syrie et de toute une série
d'événements qui ont eu lieu qui amène à
ce que c'est un pays qui aujourd'hui est
assez dangereux enfin je veux dire il y
a des conditions objectives pas
seulement pour profiter de faciliter
européenne que de quitter la que de
vouloir quitter la Syrie donc tous ces
sujets faut les prendre à bras le corps
et pas avoir une réponse immédiatement
policière parce que ça ne règle pas
surtout c'est inefficace si ce n'est
faire croire en français
étaient réunis un hasard du calendrier
si j'ose dire et ils sont tombés
d'accord sur une réforme qui prévoit un
système de solidarité entre-amende dans
la prise en charge des réfugiés un
examen accéléré des demandes d'asile
afin de renvoyer plus facilement les
migrants vers leur pays d'origine c'est
une bonne chose pour vous je sais pas je
sais pas parce que je l'ai entendu
tellement de fois parce que qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire envoyer plus rapidement
examen plus rapide est-ce qu'on bâte les
dossiers ça je ne sais pas et je le je
vais pas je viens de le dire le problème
des grandes migrations que nous avons
devant nous ce que nous disent toutes
les offices internationaux mais je veux
dire il faut les prendre à bras le corps
et arrêter de considérer que c'est par
des mesures de fermeté qu'on va régler
ce problème là-dessus puisque il y aura
vraisemblablement en débat sur la
politique migratoire au Parlement à
l'automne entre la proposition de loi
les propositions de la des républicains
et le projet de loi du gouvernement
est-ce que pour vous il faut durcir la
politique migratoire non je dirais pas
comme ça et j'observe qu'en plus faut
pas que ça serve de l'heure et de
diversion à d'autres sujets voilà je
suis préconise je suis pour qu'on ait
une politique migratoire je suis pour
que nous ayons le contrôle de qui vient
sur le territoire national mais pas
cette surenchère permanente qu'il
faudrait être plus dur toujours plus dur
toujours je veux dire plus l'autre jour
même une discussion sur l'aide médicale
d'État qui devrait être supprimé alors
que franchement en termes de santé
publique collective quel que soit on a
tous intérêt à ce que les gens qui sont
sur les photos nationales d'urgence
et de limiter cette possibilité là
encore qu'on comprenne bien tout citoyen
a mis intérêt quel que soit la situation
sociale de la de la de l'administrative
de quelqu'un à ce que il ne soit pas
porteur de virus donc on en vient à dire
n'importe quoi et à mettre en danger
compris nos concitoyens en croyant au
contraire les protéger donc et puis
surtout je vois bien comment ce thème
revient alors que j'observe que ce pays
est traversé aussi d'un grand problème
d'inégalité d'injustice etc et qu'on
ramène sur la table pour faire oublier
d'autres sujets c'est assez pratique et
assez politicien de revenir en
permanence là-dessus pour dire que ce
serait le problème majeur du pays on a
vu comment la droite a essayé de se
refaire un peu une unité dernièrement
bon et je vois bien vous savez quand
vous avez une force électorale comme
l'extrême droite qui a 20 25 % vous avez
une certaine volonté de la part de
certains d'aller draguer pendant
l'extension un peu triviale l'électorat
du rassemblement national en répétant on
peut ou Proust que dit ces dirigeants
depuis des années bah écoutez j'ai vu la
dernière fois la une d'un journal qui
paraît le dimanche avec Monsieur Ciotti
monsieur Retailleau
et nous on est des vrais sur
l'immigration je rappelle que Monsieur
Darmanin avait quand même un débat avec
Madame Le Pen c'était il y a 2 ans où il
a trouvé un peu molle sur les questions
de lutte contre l'islamique de
l'immigration ça c'est la tonalité
générale tout le monde court après en
disant Le Pen en fait c'est un sabre de
bois contre l'immigration moi je vais
vraiment faire le boulot bon au bout
d'un moment quand on voit que là encore
notre pays est traversé de grandes
inégalités que notre service public de
l'école de l'hôpital est en danger
j'aimerais qui est la même fermeté la
même détermination pour s'occuper de ça
parce que ça c'est le quotidien des
Français
jusque dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
hier vous avez immédiatement observé une
minute de silence au moment où vous
examiniez la proposition là du groupe
lyaute qui visait à abroger la retraite
à 64 ans elle a été vidée de sa
substance envahir est-ce que liott a une
raison de retirer son taxi un matin pour
vous je les laisse libre de cette
décision peut-être que nous on aurait
fait un peu différemment mais d'abord
j'aurais profité de la séquence pour
continuer à discuter et que tout le
monde comprenne le scandale
anti républicain qui est en train
d'avoir lieu non mais ça c'est le sujet
c'est pour ça qu'au bout d'un moment on
en a rabattu tout le monde parce que je
vous cache pas qu'on était tous avec un
goût de sang on peut dans la bouche et
une certaine émotion puis des choses se
sont précisées mais pendant une heure ou
deux on ne savait pas l'ampleur de ce
qui avait lieu aussi vraiment en plus je
forme le veut que j'espère que comme un
fond ne perdra la vie dans tout ça donc
évidemment dans ce moment-là on est un
peu fébrile on cherche mais au-delà de
tout ça il y a un sujet pour la première
fois depuis 1958 ça n'est jamais arrivé
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale a
actionné l'article 40 pour empêcher la
réintroduction de un article avait été
supprimé en commission pour qu'il puisse
être débattu à l'occasion du seul moment
où les députés ont de l'initiative
parlementaire qu'on se comprenne bien je
défends pas la boutique France insoumise
quand je dis ça ni même celle de la
nupes écoutez-moi ce qui sont peut-être
dans le passé c'est le droit de
l'opposition le droit d'in parlementaire
si on accepte l'idée que désormais on
nous empêche d'avoir d'initiative
parlementaire au nom d'un argument
totalement bidon parce que l'article 40
il n'est généralement pas actionné sur
beaucoup de sujets je peux vous faire la
liste de tous les textes ou n'est pas
actionné uniquement parce que les
macronistes savaient qu'ils étaient
minoritaires à l'Assemblée ne voulait
pas subir une défaite ça c'est pas bien
normalement symboliquement le président
et ce vote vous l'avez perdu
qui n'a rien à voir madame je vais vous
dire
oui mais quand même j'étais en
commission on peut quand même discuter
dans l'hémicycle la Commission est un
une représentation déformée de
l'Assemblée nationale ne jouons pas
autour on sait très bien que pourquoi il
ne voulait pas au vote parce qu'ils sont
mauvais perdants ils ne voulait pas
perdre et puis allons à l'essentiel la
retraite à 64 ans imposée aux Français
tient moins de la loi que de
l'ordonnance d'anciens régimes pour la
première fois un texte fondamentale qui
vous concerne qui me concerne qui
concerne des millions de gens n'aura
jamais été adopté par un vote à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est inquiétant
quand même 49,3 ou astuce de 47 ans pour
que le débat se limite en première
lecture qui peut tolérer ça qui peut
tolérer ça et quand nous voulions enfin
nos amis Biot et nous les soutenions qui
est un vote à l'Assemblée nationale pour
savoir qui est majoritaire qui
minoritaire ils utilisent quelque chose
qui n'est jamais utilisé et et Madame
Van Pivet c'est c'est dégradé elle-même
dans sa fonction elle doit être
président de l'Assemblée nationale pas
méprisante de l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui elle représente le groupe
des macronistes moi je suis pas mais
elle s'est abîmée et elle l'a entendu
hier on le lui a dit en termes cru pour
qu'elle comprenne normalement moi je
sais pas je suis peut-être un peu vieux
jeu je pense que quand on est président
d'une institution bien sûr je sais
madame bonprivet a été élu sous les
couleurs du parti de Monsieur Macron
mais on doit quand même défendre
l'institution et et d'ailleurs ce que
madame brompte avait dit à la presque il
y a quelques semaines auparavant et elle
s'est fait imposer sans doute sous
pression de Madame borne et surtout sous
pression sans aucun doute du président
de la République le grand débat que nous
avons c'est comment la tension entre
l'ultra présidentialisme de la 5e et le
pouvoir parlementaire n'est pas encore
plus dégradé que le président impose
c'est le sujet je vais vous dire que moi
je suis bien sûr je suis amer soit
beaucoup de choses mais je pense que le
temps est venu de la discussion sur le
changement des institutions c'est devant
nous des millions de gens ont compris
qu'on leur imposé un texte minoritaire
dans le pays jusqu'au bout pendant des
mois il est resté minoritaire par des
institutions qui sont tranquilles
démocratiques il est temps de penser à
la Sixième République dans débattre des
discussions qui sont en cours sur la
réforme des institutions autour de Yaël
brun piset est-ce que vous allez
continuer à y participer
un patron comme Olivier fort
de débit de boissons alcoolisées étaient
responsable de la lutte contre
l'alcoolisme c'est à peu près la même
chose c'est-à-dire que vous avez
quelqu'un qui brutalise le Parlement qui
utilise des choses jamais vu depuis 1958
pointée à son opposition et qui nous
réunit pour voir comment on va rendre la
situation depuis démocratique au bout
d'un moment bon je veux dire il y a un
peu de décence et de ce point de vue là
c'est aussi une erreur que fait il y a
une bande privée elle a totalement
anesthésié fait ce groupe de travail
n'existe plus elle l'a tué hier dans sa
décision avant-hier d'activer l'article
40 évidemment mais on n'est pas des gogo
on n'est pas un pot de fleur qu'il pose
sur leur vitrine pour décorer leur
rouvrir et leur fourberies parce que
c'est ça qui a eu lieu et nous l'avons
dit fermement à descendre convaincre
donc actes donc de toute manière y
compris c'est pas un groupe de travail
je vais vous dire une chose c'est pas au
député de discuter de ce que des droits
que doit avoir les députés c'est au
peuple au peuple souverain d'en discuter
moi là encore j'ai dit tout à l'heure
que j'étais vieux jeu fidèle à
l'histoire de France assemblée
constituante on a toujours fait comme ça
le peuple doit élire des députés
constituants qui vont discuter de quelle
nouvelle institutions nous voulons moi
ce que je propose c'est en finir avec
cette ultra présidentialisme revenir un
régime avec plus de pouvoir au Parlement
plus de contrôle citoyen possibilité
d'intervenir pour les citoyens avec des
référendum si le demande pourquoi pas en
révoquant les élus et que ça c'est
passionnant parce que le peuple en se
posant une question pourquoi ils savent
si en autant comment il contrôle ses
élus le lien entre représentants
représenté voilà et pas la pitrerie
qu'on a eu c'était une petite rue pour
vous bah c'était assez dégradant quoi de
réunir des députés en leur disant on a
toute une chose à vous dire vous ne
pouvez pas voter bon à quoi on sert
alors à quoi ça sert je veux dire les
Français loin ça coûte cher tout ça
l'Assemblée nationale c'est un budget
important donc si c'est un théâtre qui
jouait d'avance c'est-à-dire qu'on vous
supprime vos droits savent ça ça fait
monter quoi dans le pays l'anti
parlementarisme le sentiment que tout ça
est une bande de bavard inutile ce qui
est le sentiment de certaines personnes
déjà donc si les gens vont dire c'est
quoi ça sert d'aller voter il y a qu'une
élection importante c'est l'élection
présidentielle et là on devient sur un
autre type de régime quasi plébiscitaire
bonapartiste nous cherchons notre
champion ou champion une fois tous les 5
ans nous sommes adultes une fois tous
les 5 ans et des mineurs en culotte
courte le reste de l'année nous
attendons que papa président ou maman
Présidente nous impose un texte moi je
suis républicain et je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec ce type de conception vous
avez déposé votre notion de censure elle
est en train de d'être déposée on bande
débattre oui façon générale aura lieu la
semaine prochaine
honnêtement je crois qu'elle est pas
déposée elle est posée aujourd'hui mais
qu'importe elle sera débattue en début
de semaine ce sera de toute la nuque je
le souhaite
je crois que si je crois que c'est
Elliott est-ce que tu participera aussi
à l'heure où je parle c'était pas encore
très clair
mais de toute manière
sur la table avec une nouvelle motion de
censure on y a réfléchi mais
on peut pas banaliser ce qui a eu lieu
et le seul outil parlementaire que nous
avons pour le dramatiser au sens positif
du monde c'est-à-dire que y est une
discussion qui a un moment là-dessus que
nous puissions à l'occasion de celles et
ceux qui portent entre parole monter à
la tribune dire pourquoi nous le faisons
je veux que les Françaises et les
Français entendent quel est le problème
le problème n'est pas une controverse
entre la France insoumise et le parti de
Monsieur Macron c'est quelle conception
de la démocratie de la règle commune je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure que dire tout
ce que nous avons été émus
collectivement quelque chose qui nous
dépasse nous faisons nation vous et moi
on n'a pas sans doute pas les mêmes
idées les gens qui l'auraient non plus
mais nous sommes un peuple un peuple
souverain parce que nous avons des
règles communes que nous acceptons la
même façon que quand des enfants sont
frappés Annecy je me sens concerné parce
que nous sommes une patrie et
républicaine sur la base de droit etc
s'il y a plus de règles c'est à dire
qu'en gros en fait les règles
démocratiques sont piétinées par le camp
le clan même du président ah c'est la
nation même qui peut se stocker ce qu'on
va il y a la motion de censure est-ce
que après la motion de censure si elle
est rejetée ce sera la fin du combat
politique pour vous non
non évidemment pas
faire la politique madame vous savez
c'est un long combat que nous menons et
mais je dirais que il y a des conditions
qui sont en train de mûrir peut-être
même en train de pourrir pour que nos
idées avancent et notamment celle de
d'un changement depuis démocratique de
cette 6e république dont je viens de
parler mais à court terme qu'est-ce qui
vous reste et puis cette réforme des
retraites ne rentre pas en vigueur
est-ce que vous actez maintenant qu'au
1er septembre elle rentrera mon rôle
n'est pas dacté
le combat politique continue déjà hier
nous avons fait un serment l'engagement
j'aurais dû vous l'amener nous l'avons
mis sur les réseaux l'engagement que si
nous arrivons à responsabilité nous
abrongerons la retraite à 64 ans donc on
fait le serment que nous allons utiliser
toutes les possibilités parlementaires
toute la nuit pêche vous le verrez sur
les réseaux et c'est dommage parce que
avec le drame d'Annecy on n'a pas pu le
solenniser comme nous voulions que nous
souhaitons toutes les possibilités les
opportunités
quand la gauche est arrivée au pouvoir
elle a fait la réforme Touraine qui a
augmenté la durée de la nuitée
la gauche dont vous parlez c'est
peut-être pas la même chose François
Hollande toute la gauche oui mais c'est
Hollande que aujourd'hui la nuit pèse
c'est pas le même programme et j'ai
justement essayons de pas enfumer les
gens c'est pas c'est pas François
Hollande ce que nous faisons le
programme est différent et justement je
voulais en venir là-dessus c'est quand
même dans le serment là on fait que nous
irons vers la retraite à 60 ans donc les
amis qui m'écoutent nous allons
continuer à mener la bagarre à
l'occasion de nos niches tout ça et puis
surtout nous travaillons politiquement à
l'alternative et de ce point de vue là
la nuque c'est une bonne chose et elle
doit continuer je lance le message à
bonne entendeur salut elle doit
continuer nous avons besoin pour
emporter les prochaines élections en
particulier l'élection présidentielle
alors justement puisque vous lancez un
message à la nul et peut-être aux
Antilles ben demain Bernard Cazeneuve
lance son mouvement parce que après
Carole Delga qui a réuni ces troupes à
Montpellier la semaine dernière la
critique de la nuque est en train de
monter en puissance non mais c'est comme
pendant l'été il y a des festivals un
peu partout en France et là il y en a un
festival non mais c'est un moment c'est
un moment fort culturel c'est
intéressant non mais moi j'ai eu des
mots durs après monsieur kazemmes et je
ne veux plus en avoir ça sert à rien un
homme qui on a des désaccords avec lui
je veux pas je suis trop taquin dans
certains points de vue par contre je
vais prendre mon Rachid themal le
sénateur qui était là maintenant bon
j'ai vu tout à l'heure qui dit au
sénatorial on fait rien avec la fi on
travaille avec le PS et les écologistes
avec le PC les écologistes puis après
quand vous l'interrogez sur Cazeneuve
ils disent que nous enseigner François
Mitterrand faut d'abord rassembler sa
famille puis après la gauche etc bon moi
je suis et il dit qu'il est d'accord
avec Cazeneuve bon ben s'il veut le
rassembler la gauche nous sommes là donc
faut bien discuter avec nous
non mais je veux dire le problème de
Monsieur cazen c'est qui se construit
une identité où nous sommes
infréquentable
donc c'est perdant c'est une impasse
politique au-delà de ce que je pense de
Monsieur cazen de ce que Cazeneuve pense
de moi moi la seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est pas faire émerger une
personnalité c'est comment on gagne en
2027 comment on change le pays comment
on comble les inégalités comment on
répond l'urgence écologique démocratique
donc
l'histoire personnelle de Monsieur
Cazeneuve c'est une chose mais sa ligne
politique est une impasse c'est la
défaite aussi talentueux soit-il il ne
réglera pas ce problème soit il est pour
l'Union et donc avec nous ou alors c'est
une folie d'imaginer que le camp de ceux
qui ont fait 22 % un dernier avec son
présidentielle on peut pas les
fréquenter qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
l'union avec qui avec les macronistes et
ça c'est une note line politique donc il
pense de deux Lune soit il est le
candidat du remplacement du macronisme
et je pense qu'il est pas le mieux placé
d'accord soit il pense qu'il est le
candidat de l'Union mais c'est
nécessairement l'union avec nous sinon
il sait le candidat de la défaite donc
je laisse monsieur cazen se réunir moi
vous savez ce que je veux dire ça
m'intéresse quasiment mais je vais sur
son site la convention pour l'instant je
vois pas de programme je vois rien donc
je sais à quoi il ressemble un costume
impeccable une mine parfaite et sans
aucun doute un verbe parfois un peu
moins vif que le mien mais ça c'est pas
majoritaire pour gagner il faut aussi
les Français leur proposer des choses un
horizon je ne sais pas ce qui propose
mais après moi j'ai pas de mépris que
tous ceux
donc vous êtes prêt à discuter
un programme c'est lui qui est pas prêt
à discuter lui avec d'autres c'est lui
qui est une ligne de défaite moi j'aime
la victoire merci beaucoup Alexia merci
d'avoir été notre invité politique ce
matin on passe tout de suite au club des
territoires